what do you think of this story dental
researchers say
what made you talk about that just
because gary's sitting there
did you hear the news that gary
supposedly over vacation was trying to
get another set of new caps
i'm getting them these are temporary
what are you talking about those are
temporary
gary what are you going to give up right
okay here's what he keeps going to the
same day wait a minute he's had those
temporary cats for 20 years
here's what happened i had on the vaca
during the vacation i had those
last set of caps uh drilled off uh-huh
what is wrong with your teeth that they
think they can fix
they think that they can make the caps
smaller a little bit smaller
i don't think it's that they need to be
smaller i think they need to be in your
mouth
yeah i mean gary cannot get his lips
over his teeth
he just didn't move with his lips i know
he can't get his lips over his teeth so
listen to what i went through
so what do you mean make smaller you
know make them a little bit smaller
you know what i was thinking about you
what would you stop doing that with your
upper lip
when i get nervous like he's like
pushing his t
he's trying to cover his teeth with his
lips it's like a curtain
you were thinking about me now his lips
are all wet
he keeps greasing his teeth down i was
thinking you should stand further away
from people and your teeth will look
smaller
maybe you just stand too close yeah like
africa
yeah so anyway so listen to what
happened so i had the old ones drilled
off
they put the temporaries on yeah and i
went back and i was supposed to have the
new ones put on
uh right before new year's day but um we
didn't like the way the color came out
so yesterday
i went to this lab down on park avenue
yeah i had all these people around me
with all these fake teeth
that have numbers on them trying to
match the color whatever's on your teeth
now is way too white
well these are just temporaries yeah
these aren't these should have been in
for like a week
so i'm getting the good ones because
you're having a hard time talking aren't
you yes these are really bad i know you
talk about the genetics
while he's talking sometimes his lip
actually gets caught on his teeth
no because these are these are really
dry and really bad so so the new ones
are being put in tomorrow afternoon
oh could they make your teeth with an
irrigation system yeah can they
find something that could self-wet
you know we can go to as a people as a
country we can go to the moon but we
can't find decent teeth for gary
the temporaries are only meant to be in
for a few days i've had them for like a
week and a half
you don't mind he you know the constant
changing of the teeth
no no actually i got to tell you he
enjoys it i'm going to make the
statement right now
no matter how they turn out this is it
this is your left
stoppers you know it was really hard
because you go in there and they give
you like all these needles i mean i got
like four or six needles all over
yeah that was for one you're numb from
like your eyes to your neck i mean right
um
because you know his teeth i mean he's
got such huge teeth
this is like not water this is like
restoration of a building wait a second
that's not why they have so why do they
give you 900 shots
because they have to drill the they have
to actually drill your teeth off the
caps
hoofa you know
how many hours were you in the chair um
two and a half
whoa and it probably sounds like they're
breaking up cement in new york city yeah
right
you know what they do they take the
drill and it's just like marathon man
yeah they go right down the front of the
tooth and then they go down the back so
that they split the tooth in half and
then he gets out
maybe maybe they you buy it from is
there a whole bunch of junk in your
well maybe they buy it from like a
dental place but it's nothing more than
just a good pair of pliers
and they take this pair of pliers and
they yank the tooth out wow so it's
oh and there's nothing in it though
actually that's what believe it or not
that's what hurts the most
when you when i have my teeth off yeah
the cold air you know bothers them
my teeth are awesome and you look like
i've seen you with your teeth off you
look like eddie munster
but these the ones that are in now are
really really really dry
and they're you know just bumming me why
are they so dry because they're just
like
they're not the real thing they're just
they're not meant to be in there for
why can't they give you temporaries that
are wet when you stare at me
they just seem to dry right out they're
so funny they really do though
he just did that thing with his top lip
it's so funny i hope they catch that on
the camera it's a very subtle thing
and your lip all of a sudden gets caught
on your teeth it's a funny i don't know
whatever
i i can't even i don't know what to do
now then it pops off your teeth yeah
have you ever seen it stuck like half of
it'll be stuck
and the other half goes up it's pretty
wild your whole teeth and
lips and mustache we'll see robin i
can't see myself in the mirror